[Música]
meu nome é o da bar eu sou do grupo
galpão
sou atriz há muitos anos né
fui aluna do circo do seu lé
hoje nós vamos falar de cultura né
eu acho um momento maravilhoso para
falar da cultura por causa do desmanche
que tá tendo da cultura nesse momento
nesses países estão sofrendo um
desmanche cultural se terrível mas eu
comecei a me interessar por cultura
quando menina muito tempo porque meu pai
era músico e minha mãe cantora de igreja
e eu vivia densa nesse mundo de meu pai
tocava em circo então um primeiro
contato com a arte cultivo com circo até
um teatro a primeira vez convite atas
impõe no circo porque o circo
antigamente que é também uma coisa que
eu vou deixar aqui meu a minha revolta
que o circo está na miséria está
acabando
eu fui muito deixou me muito circo bom e
artistas maravilhosos que eu vi meu pai
tocava a música então é é minha cultura
começou assim era circo e via também as
coisas da igreja que acontecia no seu
case e onde hoje a rodoviária ali era
uma coisa chamava a é que a exposição
era a mostra feira de amostras que tinha
ali e abril as coisas da indústria todas
caso expostas é escola ea fazer a
discussão lá tinham de abelha de suas
coisas em apiários dentro tudo lugar que
pintinho que nascia lugar lá de chocar o
ovo num
um ao outro belo horizonte e tinha rádio
inconfidência que tinha um programa de
auditório maravilhoso onde eu conheci os
artistas mas é a grande importância à
rádio inconfidência que também está
sofrendo um desmanche mas é isso depois
eu eu eu fui para a faculdade eu estudei
dada foi que a faculdade fazer ciências
sociais da faculdade tinha o dna que foi
o lugar que eu me achei no dna que eu ia
pra lá longe ou fugir um pouco daquela
linguagem muito especializada da
linguagem científica aquelas discussões
aqui e é num momento também muito
político eu entrei na faculdade de 70
então é um momento que é que nossa em
plena ditadura é tinga polícia dentro da
sala de aula então assim a gente chegava
da fafich para poder estudar de manhã
estava tomada pela lpfp toda tomada com
bandeira lá pregando quanto como 'lista
conteúdo chopeira a porque o comunismo é
um monstro assim quando a gente pensa
que tinha acabado com isso ó isso
voltando de novo o comunismo é um
monstro problema da educação o comunismo
é é uma loucura um período que a gente
tá vivendo agora também mas naquela
época muito duro mas sobrevivemos né e
odeia a foi assim uma maravilha porque o
de ar onde eu conheci univerti atriz
eu vejo gilberto gil canta a primeira
vez que ele cantou carlice e aquele
mundo foi mexendo comigo aí um dia eu
peguei e vestir de mendiga sem ben ben
fahrat pada sujas e e peguei o jornal
estava tinha lá uma matéria de uma de
uma casa que estava abrindo partir
recepção de gala de luxo com flores da
holanda kombi fernando c.da
onde eu começo a ler e tio o guilherme
que beleza a sorvos e da lan e glenda
aquilo assim e é alguma coisa que
chocava as duas realidades e eu achei
que isso é bem melhor que você coloca
jornal
aí eu saio da fafs sai da parte física
uma
eu não aguentava mais a linguagem
científica uns livro que eu não entendia
os assuntos que eu não queria o povo
implicando comigo implicavam comigo que
eu estava lendo jg da luz jorge
o livro da minha mãe depois idi som de
preto e eu no reino aquelas rima achando
bonita em que coisa mais idiota você
fica lento
se o homem estivesse lendo pelo menos
maior covis que ficar vendo essas poesia
não sei o que eu achei aquilo um
desrespeito e fiquei muito envergonhada
porque eu não sabia quem era maria covis
aí passou eu numa numa livraria tinha
uma banca laci liquidamos lhe toda um
real eu chego lá e começa olhadinha
poetas russos e óleo tinha maiakóvski
seu corpo e aí eu fiquei apaixonada
pelos poetas russos é a minha formação
profissional gente ela é assim eu nunca
entrei em uma escola
falei vou fazer um curso de teatro nem
vou fazer primeiro o antigo do torcedor
como normal não é
eu saí da universidade já sim eu quero
fazer teatro
eu já tinha visto o zé celso eu já tinha
visto os grupos apresentando aqui - onde
reinam
não quero fazer teatro e aí eu fui atrás
do eid ribeiro que era um diretor já
tinham surgido peça dele ele falou isso
chega numa hora ótima porque eu tô
começando a dirigir uma peça e e
eficácia minha assistente
eu achei que era importante para dar na
foi pra lá só que eu não servia para ser
assistente gente quando os meninos
começava a encenar e começava da o texto
ficava como o texto da mão
meu olho não conseguia ficar no texto
você nos linha vendo como é que eles
faziam
de repente eles faziam assim pra me dar
o texto aí eu ia procurar esse alannah o
teu deus e não há há há
não dá mas você pode ficar e se ajuda na
produção eu fiquei acompanhando a
procissão até a estreia isso foi minha a
minha entrada assim estudar teatro
eu chego que em belo horizonte lá de são
paulo enquanto e tem um grande encontro
aqui que o instituto de ti dos dois
diretores do teatro livre de munique
o epa poder dá um curso oficina de
mulher é o de teatro pra nós e quando na
nós ficamos doido porque era uma coisa
companhia global tour deste ano aquela
coisa enérgica no pique no pique
a gente estava abraçado em roda assim
fulano e falando o mesmo texto até à
exaustão um cão entrou na cozinha e
roubou uma linguiça batendo tanto nele
que virou uma salsicha vendo isso a
cachorrada alvo na sepultura e recebendo
no epitácio eu te explicando a aventura
e cada hora esse tipo fala de um jeito
um cão entrou na cozinha e roubou uma
linguiça e isso seria fazer até à
exaustão quando você tá avisar o senhor
falava agora se estão com o corpo pronto
para criar e aí você começava a ensaiar
mas os alemães foram maravilhosos é uma
peça linda cohen foi a alma boa de
setsuan um eu amei fazer mas é os
alemães foram embora nós ficamos órgãos
o eduardo falou comigo teu de vamos
fazer pernas de pau porque na perna de
pau gente aprende da internet pau na
gente foi pra lá para diamantina e fez
lá na na oficina de teatro de rua que os
alemães deram na índia amantino no
festival que o festival universitário
que tinha o festival da ufmg é
maravilhoso foi o que segurou a ditadura
era a brecha que a gente precisava pra
aguentar
tá duro porque tinha curso de música
tinha culpa criança adolescente para
velho participa tudo contei da epul
galpão foi muito importante porque a
gente fazia oficina da oficina
apresentava e e existe a multa assistir
tudo e por um artista você tem um leque
assim de jay de espetáculo para a sede
de variados música teatro porque tudo
que alimenta o teatro tudo teatro e
música têm artes plástica tem dança tem
som tem cantei muito chato onde é
completo né e então isso pra nós é de
uma riqueza assim eu nem gosta de pensar
seqüência foi eo galpão que as todas
essas trabalhos e foi muito bom
alá que romeu julieta fizemo ele londres
é nosso ou no globe theatre no teatro os
xeiques e subiu a bandeira do brasil que
o problema como subindo pode até chorei
mas assim soubemos o galpão onde fez
vários espetáculos nós sempre
trabalhamos por diretores é convidados
que dá jeito que fala não vamos
trabalhar com o paulo josé
não vamos trabalhar com o corpo porque a
gente sente que o momento da gente
trabalhar qualquer diretor o que eles
nos podem enriquecer o que a gente pode
passar pra frente é o que a gente vai
mudando a nossa linguagem do teatro de
amplas e que não é você faz sucesso com
romeu julieta que você vai fazer romeu
julieta e tudo igualzinho vida inteira
aí vai ficar uma porcaria não é a
linguagem que a gente está a fazer ea
gente neste atual momento do galpão
a gente está trabalhando com márcio
abreu que ele trouxe para nós uma
linguagem nova ele trouxe uma linguagem
de um teatro moderno
então nós paramos de fazer clássicos
fazer texto
naquele dia com mais em passamos a
escrever este texto
então é o marcinho assim março e abril
ele
ele convida g você a escrever o seu
protesto é você tem que escrever o que
você quer falar é e aí nós vamos
conversando em mesas em reuniões ensaios
até chegarmos a uma dramaturgia então
assim foi construído o espetáculo nós
que foi o anterior e outros que esse
nosso último espetáculo que nós
apresentando nós vamos apresentar aqui
em belo horizonte
acho que é final de maio ou princípio de
junho às do gol nós e outros uma mostra
baixa abril que é sobre esse trabalho
porque é eu estou muito mas muito
preocupada com com a cultura neste
momento está muito preocupada porque a
importância da cultura ela não é só uma
coisa que é divertida cultural é não não
é só isso ela é um mercado de trabalho
enorme
não não só para os artistas mas a
quantidade de técnicos envolvidos outros
é outras pessoas que trabalham em um
jornalismo
a divulgação a produção ao todo são são
profissionais envolvidos
você botar um espetáculo ali além dos
técnicos de luz de sondhi o cenário do
seu querer
fora esse mundo aí ô ô ô teatro em
barbalha um grande espaço que é é de
trabalho que são os carregadores nos o
pessoal do caminhão um carregador com
100 reais por dia você botar o cenário
já no palco em copas e irreais botar lá
então você vê o tema
jogadores têm o pipoqueiro tem o baleiro
tem o pessoal do aplicativo e aí o
pessoal que eu cantei o porteiro
bilheteiro então assim é é o mercado de
trabalho enorme diz que a cultura tá eu
não faço essas contas mas eu sei que me
falaram à cultura emprega mais do que a
ua a automobilístico e a empresa
automobilístico tem 11 a gente tem um
acabou acabou
a lei me deixou falar ah eu falei na
dose
eu dava se gostou de uma entrada com os
querem sair maravilhoso
[Aplausos]